[Music]
hey Outlander fans I'm Liana gelareh and
I am joined by people who you might
recognize but I'm not sure cuz Outlander
has been off for quite some time
the amazing Katrina Belle and Sam
heughan and it has been a while since
our second season about Lander and I
think the fans have been really patient
I think we need to give them a little
gift
don't you think Christmas yeah yeah
little festive yeah feels fun yeah
though we didn't have any uh how many
decorations there's no no only it's um
there bit cheap and Lily Brooke yeah
yeah we will decorate the tree later
well since we are in LA LeBrock let's
get into the festive spirit and answer
some fan questions for you guys okay
here we go starting it off with do you
have any family holiday traditions yeah
we do kinda I usually go home to Ireland
our parents make us go to midnight mass
and then my sisters and I come home and
get very drunk on hot whiskey's yay and
then we do presents Sam any traditions
for you on Boxing Day the day after
Christmas Day we all go for a big Boxing
Day walk because we've eaten so much
food and drank so much and it's always
you feel very justified to then go back
for leftovers salmon Katrina what has
been the best part of filming season 3
so far I got a break from working with
him yeah I mean this is a spoiler that
we actually haven't worked together on
this season I'm not even sure you're in
this are you no no I'm not right that's
the best part do you cook for yourself
order in or eat out all of the above who
was your first celebrity crush we were
talking about this the other day we were
talking with the Wonder Years and I'm
Fred Savage for sure
does that mean yours was Winnie Cooper
um wait no I match the uh I've got a bit
of a sub Z cash on uh casting ironic
Katheryn Winnick Vikings no your first
celebrity crush not that is that is nice
alright tomorrow you see kid tomorrow be
someone there okay I don't know can you
pat your head and rub your tummy at the
same time Pat my head and rubbed my it's
not it was supposed to be a hard thing
to do yeah apparently you guys are just
so telling you should get back yeah
would you guys ever do a lip-sync battle
against each other I don't know what
lip-sync battle time Oh God
you know actually I'd win yes we should
definitely do one now I think the prize
should be Sam just gives me lots of
presents and yeah let's do that okay
sure
we explain what a lipstick battle no I
mean I can no leave him leave him in the
dark if you could have dinner with
anyone past or present who would you
want to have dinner with I would love to
had dinner or have dinner with gore
Vidal I think he would be I mean well
especially if it was at his house in
Ravello and Italy too so I won't have
dinner with he'd be fabulous and talk
about I don't know amazing gossip in
politics and Nikolai Tesla yeah I think
he was kind of interesting and there's a
street named after him in New York was
it there's a car named Doug Lovett is my
car
I've Drive a test and a battery drove on
yeah they're amazing it seemed to be a
rocket maybe what is the best thing that
has happened to you in 2016 and what are
you looking forward to in 2017 I took a
really long holiday that was amazing I
traveled around Europe um and I lay in
the Sun and drank a lot it was great
that was probably the best thing yeah
it's been an amazing year we started no
season to an hour
season three it's uh it's been kind of
crazy hasn't it um so I guess the best
thing you sing at work and I'm saying
that I was away from work and what are
you guys looking forward to next year
I'm really looking forward to filming in
South Africa I think that's gonna be
really I'm really looking forward to
that part of the story
um and also you have being in a new
place it's gonna be fun and for people
to see I think I'm really proud of the
season so far I think it's been very
strong and different and stories are
great so uh yeah if it feels some I'm
excited for the fans to see it awesome
for the latest information be sure to
follow Outlander on Facebook Twitter and
Instagram
[Music]
you